You may think of this place as just a small town in the middle of Ohio.
But this is the place that makes the Super Bowl possible.
This is Wilson, and this is where football is born.
When I see the kickoff, especially at the Super Bowl,....
...it's hard to conceive that I actually had a part in it.
I hand-lace every Super Bowl ball and I am going to be making the footballs...
...for Colin Kaepernick and Joe Flacco.
Football is what puts dinner on my family's table.
Born and raised in Ada, Ohio, and this is where footballs were born.
I work at the Wilson's football factory...
...and I'm proud to be part of the family that makes football possible.
You're welcome, Colin Kaepernick.
My hands to your hands, Joe Flacco.
49ers, Ravens, ball's in your hands now.